so a year ago I was doing four shows a
week so I would do four live shows where
I would bring in people
um usually like five to ten guys and
girls and we would have discussions
about modern relationships and dating
um we'd also mix in political content
like I would do shows about like why I'm
pro-life or whatever topic I wanted to
talk about that week I would do a show
um guys that schedule just killed me I
was up all night I just couldn't do it I
I so recently you know I still do the
shows but I just do them once a week so
I do them Thursday nights tune in you
know that's what I'm doing a live show
here
and I started the shows with a slightly
different mentality you know I didn't
realize
just a couple things about female nature
I didn't realize how easily influenced
we were
um I didn't realize how much of a hive
mind we have you know and it I was
influenced so much by this that that
that's what made me come to the
conclusion that women shouldn't vote was
honestly your shows you know doing this
documentary where I interview men that
have been wrecked in divorce and also
interviewing the women of today that
will go on to Rack these men in divorce
um you know because most of them aren't
married it's mostly single people
um I just I came to like a lot of
different I don't know conclusions from
the show
um so it's really interesting because
when you go back through my old content
you sort of see me getting like red
pilled in real time
um because at first I would watch the
content I would sort of take it in and
it's different when you're watching it
versus when you're like experiencing it
in real life and a lot of people thought
that we casted or um only got the
craziest women for shows and you know I
mean
there's maybe you might if there's a a
crazy guest you might invite them more
than once but guys it is so difficult to
get that many people in in a week we
have cancellations all the time you just
can't oh there's no way there's no way
you can cast it um not with the budget I
had
so there was a clip of mine going viral
from one of my old shows and I actually
wanted to talk about what I learned from
this clip still say things like men are
trash Society hates that look at
everything on TV it's always the dumb
Dad what's on The Simpsons the guy doing
something stupid the woman coming to the
rescue women are Queens women
empowerment women women there's no men's
empowerment men disappear tomorrow and
society would collapse men build the
world that we complain about all the
hard jobs are done by men who's a better
companion men or women men can be alone
women can't you don't see women going
out to the woods and just roughing it
that's amazing thing all the women
disappeared tomorrow men would be fine
outside of reproduction men don't eat
women women need them
all right so a lot of people think I
have extreme opinions but I realize that
sometimes I say things and people don't
understand how I got to those
conclusions
um so this was through hundreds of shows
looking at data research and just
listening to men talk a lot of the time
okay and women and women talk
when I looked and what I realized was
when I looked into the data men
disproportionately did all of the hard
jobs
everything
they built the buildings
um they are most of the police force
most of the factory jobs and women by
and large had easier jobs you know you
can't convince me that education
daycare workers and human resources
which are predominantly women is equally
as hard as Plumbing electricity
and Paving the roads you can't there is
nothing that will convince me of this so
when I had this realization that men
really make the world run
and what do they get in return
and I I thought about how bad of a deal
men are getting because even though you
might say like and I've heard a lot of
podcasts say this like men are losers
nowadays
and when I looked into the data and um I
have I have a friend that helps me
research on this but when we included
like factory jobs truckers
um police officers as the infrastructure
of society the military
uh half of men are in a job that runs
Society it absolutely makes it run and I
thought about what they get as a thank
you and I thought huh
so as a thank you the women [__] on the
men and call them trash
that that's what they get
and it actually made me sad to think
about how unappreciative women as a
whole are of men and how little they get
in return and you would think that maybe
they would get a wife and kids but okay
maybe they don't get a wife and kids all
right but at least men used to know that
they would get respect there were some
basic Baseline respect you would get
from just being a man
and when I heard that men run Society I
never really thought about it like that
but you know then when Kevin Samuels I
think was the first person I heard
explain this when I heard him say that I
thought huh he's absolutely right they
do what do women do in society not much
um I mean
if you count the the mothers that are
addicted to like wine
I mean how many like crackhead mothers
do we have
so I want to go to the next lesson I
learned so I think that that clip was
from last summer but I actually want to
rewind a little bit before that so about
a year and a half ago
um at this point this was super early
show and you're gonna see just how low
the production was the mics were peaking
it's it's not it's not great production
value this is when I did it you know but
this show I actually brought in athletes
so I I was recruited here to play
volleyball and what what happened is
there's actually a professional
basketball team around where I used to
live so these are
um the women's team is some of the best
basketball players I I played basketball
in college best basketball players I
have ever seen in my life they are they
are so talented I'm talking like one
percent of one percent this woman
actually played in the Olympics and I
actually brought them over to have a
discussion and I I don't even think this
was the topic so this this basketball
player is the epitome of feminism female
sports is just feminism and it really
leads you to be single child listen
alone unfortunately I love female sports
but I'm just I'm just being honest so
you see her world view crashing down
when I tell her that women deserve less
money
because they don't do as much work
it but even when you come to sports
right the only sport that is paid the
exactly though no but I'm saying tennis
but yes
that's because respectfully I know men
are better than women at sports sorry
I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry you're probably you
you specifically you're probably better
than most men but in general like most
men in the NBA can dunk WNBA can't and
they and they get paid more because they
make more money like that like women's
NCAA has been at a loss for years they
don't even make money
why is that because because people don't
watch as much because it's just not as
entertaining who's I don't even keep who
runs the show who who's the top dog the
man because every time
square faces
I would watch a women's game like that
when it gets to like
certain levels like finals semi-finals I
like I watched it but like
this is like and I'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
I was a woman I would [__] hate men
I'd be like the feminist like
on an individual level what we're gonna
do is the people
just one second just that fact in itself
what you're saying do you know what I
mean and that is why there's those women
groups because of these situations it's
so hard for us to get jobs and then you
add race into it you add where you live
ethnicity all these things are so
difficult so yeah there are only women
in clubs that are only women gyms oh no
there's not meant because there's Dirty
Old Men Who wank in the corner that
comes into that yeah there's things all
put in for women because for so many
years they've been Jesus
how are we devalued we got to stay at
home and not work that [__] sounds
awesome
no but but I'm saying like like like
even even the women but that was only
that came from like the war days where
the women had jobs in the war and then
the men came home and then they took
those women's jobs so then they got put
back in the home of now you have to live
well like historically men had to fight
in war so how can we say we were
oppressed we never had to fight in Wars
and even let's talk about the pay Gap
like the reason that women are paid more
than women is because they pick
industries that make more money
so like like if you go to the most
egalitarian countries in the world where
women have more Choice the the pay Gap
is bigger
it's so funny it got I don't like I
don't like that guy in the back I forgot
I forgot his name but he was kind of
simping he's like well it's because of
the guys at the top now you know damn
well it's not because of the guys at the
top and this is what I mean like they'll
kind of guys will kind of say it to be
nice but so what do we learn here
this woman
has made it to be an elite athlete one
of the most successful basketball
players in the world she played in the
Olympics
and yet for some reason she's made it to
her mid-30s and still thinks that women
are oppressed
how do we and and I I genuinely think
that she believes it
how do we make it to this old in life
believing a lie it's because this is
where this is where
I look back it's because the simp right
there co-signed it
and women will say this to other women
and nobody checks them
even I wish it's interesting looking
back because I didn't know as much about
the history but uh
she she looked at women working in
factories and the men took their jobs
after they came back from war it's like
[__] do you want to work in a factory
but
like is that is that what we want to do
so so I continued this journey further
you see it's so interesting you guys are
going to see like the production value
just go up and up and up this was at my
old apartment so I was literally just
living in this one bedroom apartment it
was so funny I um I was in England
playing volleyball and I was just doing
reactions on the side and I just thought
to myself you know I'm just gonna do
shows a couple days a week it's easy
enough
it's not as easy as I thought I was like
I'll just bring over some chicks from
the gym some girls in my volleyball team
whatever and we'll just have a
conversation with some mics all right
that's that's what I did
I did not expect to be here I didn't
expect it to get this big
um but I want to show you another you
know world view crashing down so it's
silly to think that a bad culture
wouldn't poison a woman
when left to her own devices
um okay so this was um last summer I
think yeah this was last summer let's so
let's pull up the let's pull up the clip
but I'm saying well is it fair that
women expect it over a certain age
that's the question
because you give your best years to
someone else
she's talking about going into a new
relationship yeah I know but if you're
going to a new relationship and say this
is the car and the car has been used for
the last 15 years
who said that we gave our best to
someone else I don't even know my
maximum or my best probably I never done
to to No One my best because I don't
know I give honestly I love someone
before I don't know if I get the maximum
I can I don't know maybe I'm gonna find
tomorrow a man I'm gonna give actually
the best of myself who said that I
already gave to someone else it's about
what they think's the best it's not
about you because you're not the one
buying so the guy the guy I think is the
best man yes what they think
the men from the ages of 20 to 80 all
think that girls are the most attractive
around 22 to 24. but like this is a man
that cannot stand on his own like
honestly because if you honestly think
that you can't stand on his own yeah
because like they actually mind about
what other people think because if you
tell me that after like shaping them for
their standards that's shame it's shame
and so guilt need to be no that's just
my point of view I'm saying that I don't
have an inspired day that doesn't mean
that after because I add six-year uh
relationship I gave my best to someone
no like if a man think this it means
that he's not that confident to like get
my best because if you are a proper man
you're gonna get my best but see that's
shame and if you're saying like I'm
beautiful
I'll tell you why because you're saying
if you're a real man if you're a proper
man then you would think like me and you
know this woman is 35 years old
it thinks that she could compete with
the 20 year old are you stupid I'm not
trying to be rude but I'm like nobody
thinks you're 20. and you know I think
it was at this point
where I kind of was starting to realize
that we're all the same
yes yes well there are exceptions but
not really
um because you know even the men in the
room were still kind of co-signing it
they're like oh you're an exception
usually not no usually not
um you know she did I remember thinking
she looked young but 20
really 20. I mean
okay okay
um but the the sad thing is it's like
these women have been lied and misled
because they're told that we have all
the time in the world and the truth of
the matter is you don't and the truth of
the matter is a 20 year old is gonna
beat a 30 year old any day of the week
um there's exceptional 30 year olds that
maybe can outperform but it's definitely
not the rule and the problem is until
Kevin Samuels Russian fit and myself a
lot of people had never heard this like
they had never heard and it's
interesting how the women how the women
would say it's so awful that you would
say something like that but they never
say that you're wrong
they never say you're wrong they say
it's awful that you would say something
like that because at 35 I mean at that
point you kind of have to assume you're
it's not likely you're gonna get married
and have kids